today's guest is uh a friend of mine
from our time on the opium anthony show
and uh opium jim norton as well sorry um
he is a comedian he's one of the hosts
of the history hyenas podcast
it's uh my friend and what is not an
ally called oh
and nemesis mr chris de
[Music]
i'll stefano and tell you my stories
i'll sit and tell you my stories
yeah and then uh that guy died and then
i called yeah
god so sad huh yeah he was a beautiful
guy
what's his great guy is it drugs you
think
i think drugs didn't help him sure
but i think it was just eating you know
i personally think that
just my opinion that that he was really
[ __ ] sad and
devastated when his wife divorced him oh
his wife left him that blonde wife left
me and she cheated on him
with a busboy yeah and he found out and
then he moved to a cabinet in the woods
and was like hey i cut her a check for
whatever 200k she's out of my life
[ __ ] it i'm the happiest i've ever been
i live in the woods now every day was
like a shot of whiskey
and you know [ __ ] up no no not even
that like he would be like oh i eat
mcdonald's all day every day in the
woods
yeah he would just and he would always
post ruizing r-u-i-z-i-n-g ruizing
and so but the food was cr like the
worst [ __ ]
you know big mac with a devil dog would
syrup on it and would eat it and he was
like bruising and people started
tweeting at him ruizing
and then he just didn't wake up one day
but i think you know when you're
in your mid-40s you start doing stuff
like that anybody is
is apt to have a heart attack yeah it's
dangerous because
it's like you know that's and he's a
chef too we're talking about carl ruiz
yeah carl ruiz or ruiz yeah
and there's [ __ ] yeah r-u-i-z
everybody's seen that type of name but
and also yeah you never kind of know how
it is rue is ruiz
i'm from i say ruiz ruiz the mad cuban
yeah the mad cuban and he
dude that's gotta be your worst
nightmare you are a
chef right and your wife leaves you with
a bus boy
that's that's the rumor i don't know if
that
is actually how it happened that's what
we were told
that's what he said on you know when we
used to do opie and all that
but it's the story of the it's just it's
such a greek tragedy almost you're in
the back of the kitchen
right you're doing it you're doing a
lamb chop you're doing a scallion
right you know right you're doing the
work right then you got this little
milly freaking vanilli guy out here
right filling waters and freaking
offering extra butter
and he might have been another ruiz too
most chances are
a busboy working at a restaurant in new
jersey's last name is also ruiz
so it's all in the family it's kind of
whack because he raised her kids
like they were his own wow because those
weren't his biological children but they
called him dad and everything like that
and he just left man and then he had
just opened up this beautiful
brand spanking ass new restaurant i
believe in midtown
and then he [ __ ] died like a month
into it and was the restaurant still
going
hell yeah i think the restaurant is
closed now because he's gone
or maybe it or maybe a change something
changed about the restaurant now
but yeah he was um it was such a
shocking thing when he died
carl ruiz his breath always stunk though
so i always wondered if there was
something rotting
in inside him oh rotting he always had
stinky breath and that's no disrespect
i'm not disrespecting the dead you know
i would i wouldn't do that
but i'm saying i used to say like his
breath always smelled like hot ass
and i'm just wondering if that if there
was something always going on like a
hole or something
it seemed like he kind of took like did
one of those um zen
dip packs yeah and never took it out
never took it out
yeah like he got uh what is that thing
that women get if they leave a tampon in
for too long
um like a toxic toxic shock syndrome it
seemed like you had toxic socks syndrome
from a zen
dip it smelled like one of his tonsils
was dead and the other one was alive
yeah like just it wasn't all the way
hard but something there was some part
of him if his
of his mouth like a dead tooth or a dead
tonsil something or
food stuck but something was always
stanked and the living one
had hid the dead one and was telling the
cops he didn't know what happened to him
exactly
the living one killed the dead one yeah
that's true yeah it's true but
you know r.i.p to carl beca i love him
and i always will yeah
rrp carl ruiz yeah or ruiz ruiz
yeah call i just we call him the mad
cuban yeah yeah
the mad cuban and and that and that's
when you and i met
i was gonna say he's connected he's
connected to us
man he had such a big heart man he has
such a well yeah i guess
yeah or he didn't i don't know what
happened to him they said well because
if he died that early probably a little
heart
yeah but he had a big soul small-hearted
small-hearted yeah small-hearted and we
got
uh we got nick davis and uh dom de pedes
here too
yeah don de peta everybody then we have
enough time to get him on camera
yeah he's fine as [ __ ] too he's on
camera we can see him go
go pro or anything but nick you're cute
too thanks buddy you really are you're
one of those
rare guys that can pull off bangs
dang he is kind of hot he's got nice
bangs man dude you guys were just uh
you and i were just in um cleveland
right right cleveland at hilarity's
comedy club
thank you the last time i went through
there i sold like 500 seats
which for me that was good but this time
the whole weekend 1500 out of 1600 so
for me
that's like a new ball field and i was
telling them telling you before the show
it all started when i came on your
podcast last january
got the ball rolling but you and bert
when i did you guys back to back in the
same week
i will never forget i had i was just
telling dom this i had 99
000 followers on monday like when i came
back
you know as it came through the weekend
then you and bert released in the same
week
by friday of that week i had 139 000.
wow
so now followers who cares about the
followers it's not about the vanity of
it it's about
that gate you guys gave me a real
opportunity to gain your fans
and give me the opportunity for me to
perform for them and then they stuck
around
and they're still buying and now they're
fans of my podcast the history hyenas
and because we get it all the time
because like where'd we find you we all
sent out little services and it's always
like
this past weekend or birch show or
there's a big pockets in new york girl's
got to eat
andrew schultz and then recently the
fighter and the kid that i did a couple
of months ago
all that stuff it's all the podcasts
like it's got nothing to do with
television at all anymore it's just a
podcast on what you can how you can
maximize that on the internet
so appreciate it yeah no man look i i
i'm glad
you came and i'm glad you came back man
you got nice fingers too i know i know
if that's one of those things i've never
said to you but i've been
i've been watching your ig for a long
time and i've been friends with you i
think since 2000
and you got some of the nicest fingers
in the game and toes i didn't realize
that you're because you're wearing
thong toe sandals right now so you got
toes yeah i'd like to put mustard on
your toes and ketchup on your fingers
and take a bite out of your hot dog is
thong toad sandals is that too much for
is that like a woman kind of wearing a
thong or what is that like
you came out if you i'll be honest with
you if you came to my part of brooklyn
right with the thong toe sandals like
that there's a chant not when you're
with me but there's a chance like you
know one of my boys names pat finnegan
patty fly balls
he would hit you with a taped up wiffle
ball bat just because he would think
like why is this dude coming out with
his nose socks on yeah so you got a guy
an adult doing freaking the wor
lamest crime ever you gonna do he bro
yeah he's gonna rob a bank with a
slingshot
he used to tape quarters and nickels to
the end of a tape a wiffle bat and then
put tape around and just hit people in
the back of the head with it
and you say you just get lit up by patty
fly balls
you when i was young people used if
people if if somebody was really upset
you would go up to him and you'd be like
you're mad
yeah you would hit your throat and say
you're mad and it would
make them so much madder bro of course
there's something about that when people
you mad
yeah and then you get hit or what about
this you go like that and then they look
see i've caught you you get punched in
the stomach for that yeah
that's like an embarrassing thing but
they don't do that stuff anymore
dangerous youth why it's like white
crime it's like white
childhood right homoerotic crime i gotta
be honest with you though man the
neighborhood i grew up in
that we did that white home erotic [ __ ]
but if you [ __ ] with the albanians
the albanians and sand christians they
call them sand christians
uh in ridgewood queens ridgewood
bushwick area queens brooklyn area
bro one time we were playing ball right
somebody elbowed
one of the albanians by accident kid got
pissed off
came back 20 minutes later 10 deep okay
two of the albanians had chainsaws
active chainsaws
running on the court with the chainsaws
trying to take off [ __ ] limbs
damn yeah so nobody ever messed with the
albanians in my neighborhood
they had a gang out there but imagine
coming somebody coming at you with a
chainsaw for realsies oh yeah yeah
yeah dude i used to work i used to do um
not logging but i did yard work
for a man and uh
[Laughter]
and um yeah
you guys obviously never done any actual
work but
and i had to work with this mentally
challenged dude they called him
what was that guy's name hold on they
called him tiger cat but i don't
remember what his name was
right um ronnie yeah his name was ronnie
and they also called him go head ronnie
go ahead ronnie yeah and he
was mentally disabled right or yeah he
was mentally disabled and so one
so they we get one chainsaw between the
two of us right and he took
it you know and so i'm supposed to be
kind of the foreman and he's literally
lining up the thing and about to start
it and instead of having it on a branch
has it lined up on my
leg bruh not even like not like just
zoned out like or this is where we start
you got thick [ __ ] tree trunk legs
too
the top not the bottom no i know because
your leg i've always noticed that i mean
you i was always like really
thick legs dude absolutely man and you
never really
were shaking at me you got a thick ass
yeah yeah you do
i got a thick ass i got the ass of a d
at like a kind of like a young black
girl with down are you in shape are you
staying in shape you look in shape and
how do you feel
yeah i don't feel i feel tired but i do
i did go i did go to the gym this
morning and i'm gonna go again on
thursday
yeah and i'm going to yoga today going
to yoga today dude what's it like
different now that if when people are
selling tickets like what's that
experience like
um i would say that now it's
it actually to be honest with you the
last three shows
i've done three weeks i've done at least
one of those four or five shows i felt
like i was going to pass out and almost
actively passed out
at least one time a weekend because it's
this new thing donnie was with me in
hilarity's last weekend i was calling
for him
about 20 minutes into the set i was like
you need to be near me because i may
faint
i may go down i don't know what it is i
think it's like this pressure
that they know who you are now and you
better do well but the thing that saves
me
is because of the podcast the history
hyena podcast i'm so
honest and open about it is i was
talking to the crowd being like yo i'm
going to go down
because my podcast partner janice pappas
would call him yanni nets
because he did pass out on stage in
providence so he was always got to have
nets
behind him we're like oh this is safety
so we'll call him yanni natsuko helmet
on that dude
i know man i was like i so i'm gonna be
chrissy nets i was like i'm christy nets
right now i may go down so they were
like laughing along with it but if they
didn't know who i would have fully
passed out at hilarity's
i would have fully passed out so there's
a little bit of a
anxiety-inducing thing to it but then
it's also like
sometimes too good to be true because
that's what i'm happy that
i'm nowhere near my goal yet not even
close but i'm happy to be climbing
at the pace i'm climbing because i've
you know started out as a
of course open micro then would feature
on the mc on the road then feature on
the road and then headline you know the
low d
rooms even if i got into a rooms it
would be july 4th weekend or some
half full weekend not really getting
paid what i deserved at the time
but not you know i wasn't making any
real money
and now to start climbing and sell out
shows before i get there or sell a lot
of tickets
but it's a new thing like what do you
mean pressure like the pressure
well it's easy to perform for people i
think that don't know who you are
there's
no st you're not letting anybody down
they're going to be let that they
feel like they're going to be let down
anyway they're like got barked in or
they got a free flyer to go to a show
where as opposed to somebody now paid uh
whatever 20 30 sometimes 40
ticket price you know depending on
whatever venue you're at
you know you know how it is sometimes i
don't know if you need new shoes or not
yeah bro
dude listen man no my daughter eats a
lot of [ __ ] applesauce yeah
so it depends on you know whatever it is
and it's like
there's pressure on that there's
pressure to be like i need to these
people
they have paid money they got
babysitters i need to do what well for
them
yeah you know it's funny i was thinking
recently that i felt like a more of a
pressure
um i liked having the element of
surprise
a lot and it's hard it's a little
tougher to have it when people are
coming out they know
they coming to see you right you know
there's when people don't know how
you're going to be
yeah there's an element of you can
there's an element of surprise there's
an l there's like a
there's a mystery you can kind of play
with you know they don't know you right
you know there's like um i don't know
it's like it's a real thing if i don't
know who this guy
is then i can be
you know i i could be pleasantly
surprised i could be
um unaware of how you know how he's
entertaining me sometimes you know i
could be you know his humor could be
very unique
right whereas then if people know you
then it's different you know since
you've been at the successful have you
been out with the theaters and all that
have you taken a hot
fat [ __ ] bomb yet like a hot like a
real
fat one like just a nice cirro in front
of
you know 1500 plus just a real stinker
because it happens man well you just
take a full see it
all somebody goes that's a no-no
and it's just you're just eating it and
you start going where you from
or you stop going yo you know what's
weird
there's nothing funnier there's nothing
the only things that can make comedians
belly belly belly laugh is watching
another good comedian
bomb and a fart joke or a fart or just
not even a fart joke just an
actual just a wet nasty [ __ ] rip your
[ __ ] third gear fart like that guy in
barstool you see that guy on barstool
with the third gear fart uh-uh yeah
something to look up
what fo do you think the farts are get
nastier in certain countries or not
i think yeah well i think that's why i
think we need a wall
is because i think you know outside the
united states
those farts man that's the reason every
time trump's like we need a wall i'm
like yeah mexican [ __ ] are dirty
we get that there and canadian assets
too man don't sleep on canadian
don't sleep on how disgusting canadian
fart could be
poutine you know what that's like that's
cheese curd yeah i want to wall around
all that because
there's a wall around us man well why
don't everybody should just get a little
wall that they can bring with them
and put wherever they want canada and
mexico because the truth of the
situation here we got a man right here
doing something there's a bourbon guy
right here this is the
ain't never hear a fart hit third gear
as the couch okay take a look
and they're going to blame it somehow on
white people i'm sure dude that's insane
right wow drift huh
dude i was watching that thing for an
hour yesterday
crying my beautiful four-year-old
daughter was doing ballet
and doing some of the finest moves she's
ever done and get her to new heights in
her life
and i was head buried in the phone
crying laughing because of this dude's
third gear fart
and her mom was like this is why we
can't be together her mom was just she
was like this is why
i'm just always going to be called
parents because
i was just like yo crying she thought i
was crying
first of my kids mom thought i was
crying because how beautiful my daughter
nailed the pirouette
i was listening to that my headphones on
you know
miracle crying at the ballet look at are
they husband and wife
yes they are yeah he just blasted his
wife with that oh could you imagine what
those undies must look like
his draws must be wild i can't even
so like that would make me cry laughing
and watching a good good good comedian
or
a video of myself bombing hard yeah
where like you just can't get like
you're just eating it like i just did
the impractical jokers cruise
um and i was supposed to be on there
yeah it was it was fun man it was fun
to see a lot of fat ass people but um it
was fun well whatever you know i'm fat i
got
i'm not i'm not i'm in better shape but
i still got fat puffy nipples i'm still
a size
now i used to be 38 weights now i'm at
36. yeah so i've slimmed down but i'm
still
like i wouldn't if you were co-workers i
probably wouldn't hit on you i wouldn't
right if you were a female
well the thing is like this is i always
feel like it's
you know people have said this to me and
they're right uh i got lead a man face
best friend body that's what it is it's
a letdown it's a letdown with women with
me
usually i think it's going to be
something else i think i'm you know this
tough guys guy whatever that i got that
look some people tell me i look like ben
affleck some people tell me i look like
ben stiller
yeah big difference you look like ben
better i know that yeah
yeah yeah dude so i'm sorry
yeah yeah that matter yeah
you look like somebody who's [ __ ]
using performance enhancing drugs
to swim dude you look like ria pearlman
do i really you got real pearlman hair
she's talented
she is bro cheers was a good show
sometimes i feel like cvs is my cheers
because i'm always getting stds
yeah i'm just always in there like yo
y'all got me
oh real pearl wow extremely jewish
yeah she's got the yeah no but we said
you look like you have the same hair as
eileen wuernos oh yeah
that was an old clip with carl r.i.p
call we said that you look like eileen
wuernos the first female serial killer
ever killed
he had that kind of hair going uh but
that's all right
but um what are you talking about oh we
were saying i was saying that like yeah
like
laughing at so so you have it so since
you've been things that make me laugh
when i
think they make me oh i have not bought
no i haven't i had a this this actually
this weekend
in uh this la actually about two weeks
ago in maryland i had a tough show
right maryland yeah it was a big place
man it was 2500 so it was like one of
the biggest places that i've been in to
perform
maybe in the state's the biggest place
right you move tickets brother but it
was crazy man
and it was amazing you know everybody
that came out and stuff but
oh wow that was a quality i called that
a top of the cracker that came out right
out of the top of my ass back
sometimes it's interesting sometimes a
fart is really right on deck and then
sometimes it's
very lost and it's kind of like almost
like they have to call it to the front
of the line
like its mom just got there to pick it
up at carpool and it's like hey where's
ronnie
yeah that came out of top my ass so i
didn't even mean to time it that way but
it was one of those things where i can't
hold it anymore it's going to find a way
out and it leaked out at the top
then there was a man very similar to
that which is exactly what made the show
so tough in maryland
just a guy in the front just being just
crazy yeah right just too much sometimes
you know but um
and that stage was really big and the
acoustics were like different and so it
was like
just it was it was tougher to manage it
was like okay i'm having to manage
something that's different here like
you know the stage is bigger so how much
do i move on the stage so i try to move
up and down the whole stage
instead of just i probably should have
just took the middle third and just
moved up and down that
how how have you had some since you know
obviously with these bigger venues had a
time where you felt like you were going
to pass out even if it's going great 20
minutes into the set 30 minutes into set
overwhelming energy is that happening or
you always feel in control
when you're on stage like it's like your
safe zone i felt a lot i feel in control
i just feel like
um i think i just feel tired i think
it's just like okay
we're getting through it you know i want
everybody to see the show i want
everybody to see the tour so it's like
you know places keep popping up that we
haven't been and so do you bring the
same dudes with you
yeah yeah bring the same guy most of the
time this guy ari mantis oh great that's
nice
it's so important right to have somebody
on the road with you to keep your mental
health oh he helps me so much because if
you sit there alone i don't care how
successful you are you start to really
think about
everything and then it starts to real so
that's why i like having don and i got
my other boy sergio chico and they come
out with me
yeah he's like our event is like a
service animal man he's great dude you
like
he's always level-headed he's always the
same like if i'm losing my mind or
something yeah because you're sober too
right he's always the same
yeah that's why i got don don's a piece
of [ __ ] he's doing drinks and he's oh
yeah
yes i am yeah but don is good because
don's always down for a good time
sergio is one ten years sober wow
boxing instructor so when you you know
when we go on the road you come back
that monday and you're like oh man i
gotta hit the gym
i i [ __ ] up with sergio you come back
like yo i could take monday off
wow cause he's got you up at 7am doing
drills working
so it's good to have him i like having
both guys that's that's unfair a little
bit
donnie and i do work in a workout donnie
does work out that's right
i mean donald johnson's a sex addict i
believe all of that i believe that dom
works out he doesn't i don't believe
that he works that he seems like a guy
that works out
right wow yeah i have i don't know you
know
some men have like a v i have an h it
just goes straight yeah no you look good
with no shirt on
thanks okay nice i believe it man look a
lot of men look good i think
um i'm one of those guys like i just no
matter what but not
sexual good that's what i'm drawing like
there's a lady right here with a
question for me
yeah hey theo and chris i hope you're
both doing well
um so my question is for both of you i
know chris
has mentioned he's played high school
and college basketball so if you had a
pickup game of just stamp comedians
who would be your starting five and why
thanks for everything great questions
you want me to go first um
well i lose by letting you go first go
ahead you go first then
okay i'm gonna go first so this is a
great question by the way
it is a great way we gotta do like the
playground theo gets a pick then
uh on the snake chris gets two chris
gets two and then theo gets to all right
we'll do it like that go ahead you go
first theo
[ __ ] um years ago they tried
is this uh was your first pick
years ago is this live uh
hold on my first pick uh i need a
basketball player i need somebody
you know i'm honestly i am thinking
urban out of the gate
i'm trying to see who's out there that's
a good player
that maybe used to play you're already
taken
i'm going to go with um right i'm going
to go with my boy
i'll go with brendan schaub i'll put him
down in the past yep i was thinking too
i want to only pick black guys so i'm
going to start off with andrew schultz
my first one and then so i got blood
[Music]
do more than three seconds of fashion in
the paint you're out so i'm gonna take
andrew schultz as my as my first black
eye
and then um second i'm gonna take um
second i'm gonna take uh i'll take uh
dave chappelle wow yeah does he hoop i
don't know but
it's just nice to have two black legends
on your squad respect respect
i'm gonna go with um
uh this is so tough even though i have
this wall right here to help
i'm gonna go with
get me
you get two you take two okay then i'm
going to go with
i'll go with andrew santino hmm nice
he's gonna go one more right yep
and i'm gonna go with um i'll probably
roll with leslie jones
nice that's a nice pick that's defense
that's defense andrew
so now i've picked my final two okay so
my final two
um i'll say i will go with
my second pick um i'd like to go with
eric griffin nice yeah
he's tall he can coach when he yeah yeah
well no i gotta i gotta pick for who my
coach is gonna be okay um
and then for the fifth my final i'd like
to round it out
i'll round it out with bill burr wow
i'll round it up with bill bird just a
tough boston guy that you know
will miss one shot and start punching
people in the face cause a fight i like
that okay i want to like a scrappy white
dude
that's gilbert respect man i'm gonna
roll then
i need a little bit of outside i'm gonna
need a shooter from the outside
so i'm going to go with
i'm going to go with
give me uh give me sebastian i'll take
sebastian
he stays in shape yep and i could see
him
it might be really hilarious to watch
but i could see him someone shooting a
three-pointer yeah yeah yeah
yeah and those pants and i can see him
jumping when he does it he needs to jump
yeah
you got one more pick all right i got
one more pick then i need
i'm gonna need a little bit more help
down in the paint i'm gonna go with
somebody long i'm gonna go with chris
porter
nice chris porter that's a nice squad
and now
coach coaching my team would like to be
coached by r shafir
okay i think he's got i think he would
have some words
that would piss people up okay
all right uh my team i think is gonna be
coached by eric griffin actually so he's
gonna have to come out of the game
sometimes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah rip him with
just riff and rest yeah yeah
so i would go coached by eric griffin
all right that's i think that's a nice
squad hopefully that answers on the
young lady's question why are y'all
going to leave kirk fox
on the bench does he yes he's super tall
and he was that he plays tennis he's
athletic
yeah i don't know if i see him doing
basketball while he was also in the
patriot which is one of my favorite
movies interesting shout out mel gibson
um i could also give yeah bobby lee
would be nice on the team
is it so oh you said now's the
basketball yeah
yeah just use him as like this
like a complaining little basketball
yeah i love bobby lee man here's another
guy's podcast the tiger belly podcast i
did oh man that was fantastic so shout
out bobby lee thank you it's so much fun
yeah what i mean obviously
what is it about the podcast i mean that
everybody i mean it definitely allows
you to know people kind of better
you know yeah well i think because i
think it's because
like when i did also andrew santino
whiskey ginger another one that helped
me it's like
you just talk for an hour or two about
anything sometimes it's funny sometimes
it's personal sometimes it's a mix of
both
divulge information people feel like
they really know you they're investing
in you it's not like a five-minute
little
tonight show set which is fine or even
an hour-long stand-up set which is still
disconnected
a podcast is like hey i'm you know me
now
right so it's like i'm listening to you
you're in my ear for an hour it almost
feels like a family member i think to
some people i know even me
when i listen to podcasts sometimes to
catch up with you guys i'll listen to
your guys podcast because i'm like
they're i'm can find out about their
life this way yeah so and i think that
easily makes an audience member buy a
ticket what i need to do personally
is stop divulging so much personal
information because i'm pissing members
of my family
and friends off because i'm making jokes
about them using their real names
cause i just get so in the moment
because right now we're just a little
sad i feel that with my whole town
yeah because right now we're just like
in a little beautiful studio but like
this could be heard by a million plus
and i'm just yelling pat finnegan that's
his actual birth name
that's his government name and he's an
active duty firefighter and i just said
he used to beat people with a bat
and he could lose his job well look or
he could gain work somewhere as a
bouncer
you know hey you got to think of the
other side of the coin you could be
doing something for
yeah uh for that because half this [ __ ]
is like you know
i'm having a good time i'm telling the
truth but i'm making it up or i'm
embellishing the details for performance
and people get pissed like
even people in my personality yo why the
[ __ ] you say that about me i'm like yo
when the mics turn off i don't even
remember what i said yeah like i
genuinely
we're talking for an hour an hour and a
half i don't know what the [ __ ] i said
i'm just in the moment having fun that's
what i see i i use some people i'm just
trying to be alive like i'm not trying
to
i'm trying to stay alive yeah while i'm
on a microphone or not
i'm trying to i'm not trying to hurt
anybody what do you use uh
because it looks like because you have
very very healthy healthy healthy hair
yeah really
absolutely man wow thanks not a lot of
people could pull off a mullet and bang
so so this this podcast crew mullen and
bangs that's our new nickname dude
forever cops
speaking of uh people um i'm not sure
what you just said a second ago but
i do want to say we got i want to call
brad williams because he remember you
know this quaid and bales thing that
happened yeah i do
yeah the young gunner this australian
young buck right
and uh and people really lighting into
them yeah but
right and brad did a fundraiser for him
and it was supposed to be to raise 10
grand and i think they raised about
a lot more i want to say a couple
hundred thousand but then unfortunately
hold on
okay sorry don't hold on you say
whatever you want yeah i'll say what you
i was gonna say i'm sorry pictures
pictures of that kid came out with him
with strippers and stuff like that did
they really so i don't think he's eight
year i don't
they say he's not eight or nine years
old but i don't care he's still small
enough
he still can't get on all the rides so
we should still just send him out there
well i mean if you want i don't know
what happened
so what i'm wondering is do we know what
happened and you guys are going to have
to put on the headphones
uh to hear brad when we call them i mean
300 thousand 000
is a lot of [ __ ] money i don't have
brad's number
all right
because this thing really captivated the
nation last week and put the phone in
the middle of the table hey brother
what's up man it's theo
hey buddy how are you doing fantastic
hey man thanks for answering the call
i'm uh we got chris de stefano here um
in the podcast right now and what's up
brad hey buddy hey uh chris i'm seeing
you on thursday yes on thursday man
we're going to do
kimmel together oh yeah a little stand
up yeah
we'll figure out duet we should we could
do that i'm down to do that
yeah we're yeah we're going to do a uh
jeff dunham
yeah hold on
but brad only if chris sits on your lap
yeah we're doing a reverse jeff dunham
yeah yeah
it's going to be great well that's your
hand up my ass it's one of my favorite
sex moves
reverse jeff dunham yeah you can you you
can get a
a reverse jeff dunham at the uh at the
uh cat house in vegas
let's do it dude that's why i'll stay an
extra night then
you don't need an extra night bro you
just stop by during the day all right
i'll do that don't be that creeper that
hangs out
brad daylight cat house
you're gonna be living in the apartment
oh god
brad we had uh we talked about the queen
bales thing on the podcast last week and
um and everybody's been talking about it
i know that you did a fundraiser for him
um can you kind of take us through a
little bit of that and where you're at
now with it
yeah no problem uh first of all uh
first of all he's nine years old
everybody okay
so stop with your damn conspiracy
theories uh
he's nine years old anyway uh i got
i got one of the video because uh i've
got some australian fans
that kept sending me the video and i
don't know
like why they kept sending it to me just
like hey you're a dwarf he's a dwarf
you can help them like i like i don't
know
i don't know what they were thinking
like cousins
yeah like i've got some hotline or
something but yeah
but i saw but i saw the video and like
anyone who saw the video who's got a
pulse i was
uh really moved by it of course of
course i
i'm a fellow little person he's got the
same kind of
dwarfism that i do and i was bullied
growing up so
it really it it really spoke to me so i
thought i got to do something but i
can't
you know i'm out in los angeles what can
i do he's in australia
so i thought well i'll throw together a
gofundme page and
send the kid to disneyland i grew up
going to disneyland kids love disneyland
so uh i did that set the goal at ten
thousand dollars because with ten
thousand dollars you can buy
them flights tickets and maybe two
churros
uh those things are expensive yeah um
and i figured you know that that'd be
that'd be a good time so i set it at ten
thousand dollars
tweeted it out and then i went to bed
and uh the next day it was at eighteen
thousand dollars damn and and then uh
hugh jackman talked about it
william shatner talked about it it
started getting passed around all these
celebrities
uh and then currently we're at 460
thousand dollars
damn that's what theo gets for a weekend
homeboy is gonna buy disneyland
and i'm thrilled about that i hope a
dwarf owns disneyland because then
probably no more height requirements
yeah space mountain all day and so
whenever the whenever the
the the conspiracy theories came out i
mean just because you know people are
skeptical of everything
um what did you do then oh man
i just kind of let it go like if
if if i chase down every person that was
talking about it or saying that he's 18
years old or that he's
he's not really 18 he's a 45 year old
actor
yeah just weird stuff yeah people saying
he's in dunkirk
he was in dunkirk yeah that's what
people were saying what were they
dropping him out of the
i have no idea he played one of the
bombs
dropping them on to the germans yeah
people were there were all kinds of
conspiracy theories people were saying
that he worked for the city i remember
somewhere else out of akron there was
all kind of wild stuff
but did you did you check with him did
you do any other recon to make sure that
you were
like did you have any question yeah i
mean i just wanted to make sure
that uh he's a good kid and that you
know he's a kid but
i got the face time with him and uh face
time with both hands
and his mom and that's back when the
fundraiser was at twenty thousand
dollars and it really hadn't picked up
yet
uh new uh news organizations weren't
really talking about it
uh so i was facetiming with him he seems
like a fun
normal kid and then once it started
going
above like fifty thousand dollars twenty
five thousand dollars
uh i started reaching out to a bunch of
different people
that run charities and do these kind of
thing
things all things all the time gofundme
is an incredible website uh because once
a fundraiser hits a certain point they
assign a team
to that fundraiser so i had a team from
gofundme and constant
cost communication and they vetted
everything they they looked into
everything they did
amazing work so and where does the money
go
well and uh we we posted an update on
the page
uh so kaden and his family actually
released a statement that said
that they are turning down the trip to
disneyland
and they want all the money to just go
to charity wow
so that's dope and he's ridiculous are
you gonna pick the charities is he
picked a charity how does it work
uh i did another facetime call with him
and his mom and we kind of went through
all
all the charities that we wanted to go
through because if you look at the
original wording on my gofundme i said
any excess money would be donated to
charity
uh so we we picked some great charities
and uh they're actually posted right now
on the gofundme page we picked uh six
different charities
uh some some charities right
yeah it's not a stomp out bullying uh
born this way those are two charities in
the
united states there's uh four charities
in in
australia we're giving about sixty six
thousand dollars to
each of those charities and then
whatever money is left over
uh i i decided to give it to kaden and
his family
and said uh you guys can spend that
money however you want i know you're
turning down money but
many people donated to this fund with
the thought of their money going
directly to the family right
and is it honored and is it 400 000 u.s
or australian
what's the currency yeah it's a 460 000
us which is over 700 000
australians yo they could buy one of
those [ __ ] they could buy the
aborigine people
with that right not all of them you
could buy probably a couple a couple of
them
yeah oh and
this is a good time to add that some of
the charities are anti-racism charities
that stand up for the rights of the
aborigine people absolutely as do i
i'm not an aboriginal person have you
yeah
i would love to i would i would love to
meet one i
know because i have a i don't think i
have any aborigine uh fans but i'm
looking for that that's one of the
things i'm trying to get from my podcast
there you go you got to get something
and yeah and and
i brad too because you know because i'm
only i'm just a victim of the internet
as well
it's like all these pictures are like oh
he's 19 years old he's with strippers
he's got guns
i mean how do they do all that like what
like
what is it listen photoshop the internet
is an amazing place
uh both good and bad i mean there were
there were people that were spreading
rumors
that like oh uh like there was some
like i looked at oh yeah a lot of this
stuff because i wanted to make sure that
the
that that the money was going to a good
spot there was
one person who had a facebook talk show
that said like that kaden was like this
nine-year-old
running around uh the school like
sexually assaulting girls and i mean
they they said that their proof was that
they read one facebook comment
that's and they posted the facebook
comment and it said oh
a friend of mine his his kid
goes to the same school and knows some
girls
this happen i'm like really you're going
through all this off of facebook
yeah that's ridiculous man yeah do you
we're going nuts
is there i mean yeah there's all kind of
stuff so many people said he opened up
for gucci mane there was all kind of
i mean well that that is the problem is
when uta signs him and he starts taking
dates away from everybody we'll get back
[ __ ] you brad
that's a great point man they signed
bagel boy
bagel boss yeah they had this kid named
lightning rod
uh lightning rod i don't want to say
lightning rodney maybe when i was
growing up some guy they got hit by
lightning and they tried to tour him
around locally
really yeah he was probably moving major
tickets oh he wasn't doing anything
maybe 40 tickets
not katie will sell out now what about
this brad are there higher costs
associated with being like a
a little person growing up like are
there costs that are there extra costs
yeah well like just in terms of i mean
at your most basic cost
uh most clothes that uh
i would like to buy uh don't fit me so
you gotta
get stuff that's uh tailored unless you
just wanna be
walking around with like a shirt that
has bob the builder on it but uh
i doubt you want that so yeah you have
extra tailoring and then plus a lot of
little people
have uh medical problems
whether it be neck or leg surgeries i've
had one
dwarf related surgery on my legs so
yeah they they can they they can get
problems that way as well so
that's why i wanted to give the family a
little bit of money just because
if those kind of things are coming up
with caden i want to make sure that
they're taken care of and that's what
the people
who gave money to the campaign wanted as
well so yeah that's dope
yeah yeah that's dope and and it's
really great and really
and and people stepped up and we ended
up donating a ton of money to charity
that's going to anti-bullying and
anti-abuse uh anti-racism charities so
a lot of people are a lot of people are
going to be helped in a very positive
way because of this
yeah not be more thankful yeah man and i
know you know because you're i'm a i'm a
dad i know you're a new dad congrats
it's like
when i see stuff like that and i'm sure
it's the same with you it's like
you can't help but think like what if
that was my child being abused that way
like you know so it's great that you can
that you made an effort and did it
because i
there's thing there's times when i see
videos like that and i'm like i can't
what if that was my daughter and then i
have a chance to donate and
i just watch pornhub or do something
different but you
actually went out there and made a
difference which is why you're happily
married and i'm you know single living
with don de peda on his couch
there's still time i still yeah that's
why i got visitation rights but you
you know but you have a full happy
family there's still time
brad uh thanks so much man and uh yeah
at least
chris will be warmed up for your podcast
later this week man hey
sounds great thank you guys gang gang
everybody uh before he hangs up can you
hear me yeah
what's the quickest way to uh get to
your gofundme because when you just
search on gofundme we can't find it
so how can we get to the actual gofundme
oh uh if you guys still want to donate
to the gofundme because it is still open
uh you can uh probably quickest way is
just to go to my twitter
and then scroll down the tweets and
you'll find you'll find links i'm on
twitter at funnybrad
and uh if not i'm sure you can just
google uh gofundme for
a bullied australian boy and something's
gonna pop up there will be news articles
there will be links
uh you can and there'll be 460 000
in there already so yeah it oh man and i
had so and i had so many friends that
were like
it really makes you realize who your
friends are because i had so many
friends
that were like uh sending me messages
like dude
embezzle it take it go to sweden and i'm
like
go to sweden yeah what the [ __ ] what if
you disguised yourself as quaiden and
went to disneyland
oh shave get shave get a tan
oh yeah oh yeah it could happen man dude
uh dude thanks so much it's such a it's
such a cool story to hear man
and um yeah just thanks for jumping on
the line with us and sharing that
no problem love you guys love the
podcast see you on thursday chris see
you thursday brad
love you man peace it's that time
that's right this winter you should
start a new routine and upgrade your
everyday life with a monthly box of
awesome
imagine a box shows up and what's in it
oh
awesome that's right a box of awesome
from
bespoke post bespoke post
sends guys only the best stuff every
month what do you have guy i got the
best
so whether you're looking to commemorate
an occasion with a
champagne saber or toast perfectly with
aged winter cocktails box of
awesome has you covered from style and
grooming goods to bar
wear cooking tools and outdoor gear
box of awesome has carefully built
collections for every part of your life
if you're not doing awesome you can be
to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome dot com your answers
will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across
a ton of different categories it's free
to sign up and you can skip a month
or cancel at any time each box costs
only 45 bucks
but has over 70 bucks worth of gear
inside
i just got my box of awesome from
bespoke post got this beautiful
uh green um traveling carry bag
and i'm really excited about using it
when i go to
maui sorry to brag but i'm so excited
right now you can get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com
and enter the code theo at checkout
that's
box of awesome.com code t-h-e-o
for 20 percent off your first box
support this past weekend get that box
of awesome and now
back to chris what a great guy yeah
about last night that's their podcast
right yeah yeah well actually uh that's
just adam ray now brad's not on anymore
oh right he's not in the pod yeah so he
um yeah brad's going to get rewarded in
the afterlife for that
you know because i don't know like
there's certain rules and regulations
with little people in the afterlife they
have to do certain tasks absolutely they
have to do certain tasks to get into
no that's that movie you're talking
about i think that's the first pride
oh that's right that's right yeah cause
i um
because yeah i wasn't trying i wanted to
ask brad but i kind of chickened out is
because
the thing is like they all kind of look
alike to me little people
so i was kind of one to be like brad
like you know brad looks different he's
you know famous and doing well but like
all the other ones like all these little
pictures it's like i don't know
it's all the same to me well dude i
respect them all but i just you know
what i don't respect them
i do i respect them all i keep my
distance safely and i respect them all
wow
i'll tell you this i saw two cats attack
uh attack a little person in hermosa
beach
and this is about seven years ago
probably about 11 years ago now i saw
two cats attack a
little person in hermosa dude and it was
insane bro it was like rome it was like
watching ancient rome go really yeah
i kissed a little woman on the lips
yeah like a couple years ago made out
after the show beautiful beautiful
spirit beautiful soul
and uh was that in where baltimore that
was not in baltimore that was actually
outside bananas comedy club
oh over there yep i made out with a
little little girl not a little girl
a little woman i made out with a little
person who was a legally aged
woman in her 20s damn what an ironic
name for the city hasbro heights
yeah there you go nikki bangs
bang hitting him hard yo dude brad was
talking about disney world too i just
came from or disneyland
which i think is a great thing that he's
doing disney world i just took my
daughter to disney world in orlando oh
wow
me my mother and my daughter and now has
it been a lifelong dream or something
has this been like one of those things
or have you taken your kid before
i wanted to take i wanted to take my
daughter from last time
delilah she's on the wall i wanted to
take my daughter delilah
to germany for christmas
this year yeah i wanted to go that's
about as christmas as you can get let's
go to germany i wanted to show her i
wanted to show her um
where christmas started yeah and where
the white race started oh yeah
where where the humble beginnings of the
like
i don't know i'm kidding
i'm just [ __ ] around you got to know
i'm just [ __ ] around i know you're
[ __ ] wrong with the dwarf jokes i'm
just kidding around well
i said i want to buy aboriginal people
and it's like they're slaves over there
[ __ ]
i'm being an idiot but don't go i said
you could buy a few i know i'd like to
buy the race yeah that's a discount man
on gofundme and also it's like
you know all those surgeries doesn't
have universal health care
yeah what are you gonna do for where in
australia yeah for the leg surgeries
that he'll he'll need
well they could yeah i just don't i
don't know if they do or not the
universe is just kidding around
they do have yeah but i'm just kidding i
just hope people know i'm just joking
around yeah because you feel like you
have to be
you have to say that now in these parts
am i not helping you with my vibes
sometimes i'll say something you'll just
look at me and just what the bottom of
you you'll just start curling the bottom
of your mullet
with your finger i'll just see what i'll
just see your [ __ ] hair it's a sign
for help
yeah you'll just be like yo i'm like
you're just looking at me you're
unbuttoning a button nicky bangs will
[ __ ]
you know don's texting women
don's in a full sex hole
so have you ever been texting somebody
like about sex you're having like a
business conversation or something with
somebody else
at the same time yeah well today on the
plane i fell asleep
i was flying jeff bloody and i fell
asleep but my phone was open and some
girl
and my snapchat was open some girls sent
her titties on snapchat while the flight
attendant i was just having my eyes
closed and the flight attendant gave me
my breakfast
but yeah those titties were open on my
tray
dude i had a woman on a plane once wake
me up from being asleep and tell me my
penis
was erect bro no bothering her yeah
really
what'd you do yeah she said your body
sir your body didn't she used to go and
manipulate
women's vaginas though for health
reasons wasn't that used to be an old
job we used to talk about it on opie yep
we used to do orgasmic meditation
right you still [ __ ] with that or no i
don't i've been there's been people
trying to get me back into it but
i think they're just kind of looking for
you know i don't know
i just it's too much time it's just i
don't have the time right now right
dude i went to disney i went to disney
world right and they were pride in
themselves
because like i said i want to take her
to germany i want to take my daughter to
germany and i said to my mom
and she's latina isn't it she's latina
she's puerto rican puerto rican she
have puerto rican half you know german
irish italian
just white yeah clock maker she's white
yeah she's just [ __ ] clock maker
just white european and then i've seen
i've seen the nutcracker dude yeah yeah
so that's just me west side story it's
just me
so so i tell her i tell
my mom i'm like hey do you want to come
with us to germany um
i want to take my daughter to germany
and you could come through i'll buy you
a plane ticket you know get babysitter
or whatever when i go out and get these
german guys you know brothels or
whatever
late night and um and my mom goes no
we're not going to go to germany
let's go to disney world and if you want
to go to germany we could just go to
epcot and go to the german country and
we can have some beers because
she's four years old why are you taking
her to germany i'm like
this is my idea i just want to show her
christmas she was like she's too young
she's not gonna have a good time
so my mother convinced me to go to
disney so we go to disney here's the
thing so first of all that the trip
starts off
disney world starts off poorly because i
had
i i um i just come off great runner
shows at gotham comedy club
beautiful new york city great my
hometown chris mozillia chris
silly legend great shows and every time
i pee it's burning
it's burning i got a little sting so i'm
like ah [ __ ] what have you been having
sex with random women i've been having
unprotected sex yep
so i'm just like for months before that
you know i probably had unprotected sex
about 40 plus women
wow yeah yeah so that's they don't call
me chrissy dripdrop for nothing
so i've since improved but you know
again bro no i like you
out there and you ain't afraid to get
you know just to be a human crissy drip
drop baby taking chances bro
yeah so so anyway so the
trip is going good first of all you know
you're in about ten thousand dollars to
have you know your mother and your
daughter
go you're in about it's about 10 g's so
first day we get there we go to the
magic kingdom and you get there
and all they do is pride themselves all
disney world does is pride themselves
on how it how friendly they are to the
uh
nature economy how do you say that how
they're um what
they're uh eco-friendly they're
eco-friendly so they're saying
they use paper straws all we do is use
paper straws you love us paper straws
then i take my daughter to get her hair
done at the bippity boppity boutique
which is the boutique in the magic
kingdom 600 [ __ ] dollars no way to
get her hair done
and extra did you get it done into dude
a hot air balloon
i could have done it to nick's banks it
was about six hundo
yeah so 600 to get her done with the
prince she got a cinderella dress
she got her hair done by cinderella so
it's a whole experience and then
and then an extra 50 bucks for tea i saw
them making the tea at a [ __ ] keurig
oh yeah in the back so [ __ ]
so it's like okay paper straws using
paper straws you'll save the turtles but
you'll rape
you'll rape the [ __ ] parents right so
all [ __ ] up so i was pissed off
because my mother had my credit card
because i was taking i was on my phone a
lot responding to emails you know
sexting i was in a full sex hole
and work hole while my daughter and
mother are experiencing these beautiful
things at disneyland
so i'm just sorry you're like i'm just
fully out of my mind right
oh yeah yeah so i'm being an idiot so my
mother's like listen why don't you i
will meet you back here in two hours
give me your credit card
and then my see my amex just getting
[ __ ] hit up
what are they doing getting tathy
caricature yeah my mom
my mom got shirts you know that wild
western drawing where
his fake gun y'all was gone for two
hours she hit my corner for twenty three
hundred dollars kiss ash
and i just was like [ __ ] so then i'm
like because then i got stressed out
when you get stressed out you have
chlamydia on deck when you have
std brewing when you get stressed out it
really starts to flow
so i was like [ __ ] i know i have it so i
called my boy who's an er
doctor and i explained to him the signs
incentives he was like [ __ ] hey drop off
a bag of salt over here
yo yo he was like that's an std man how
quick can you get back to new york new
york i said
this is day one of my disney trip we're
at the magic kingdom he goes all right
send me your location so i sent him the
location he sent gets a pharmacy
like whatever 10 miles away but in
orlando still still kind of like on the
outskirts of disney
like a oh not in disney no no but like
on the not
on the disney property but like where
disney people who work for disney
like their local cvs okay so goes out
there calls in the std [ __ ]
medication for me
so i go there swaying this everyone's
got little kids you know sore throat
medicine people buying binky everyone's
got little kims too
and i'm over there and i go i go over
there and i pick up
std medication i had a goofy shirt on i
swear i had a goofy shirt on and
i left disney hat on and i forgot
because i was dressed you know my
daughter was like you gotta dress
wear your disney [ __ ] so i picked up std
men i
took them my daughter and mother back to
the hotel i said hey listen i'm just
gonna go for a jog
and i got an uber and i went and picked
up those std meds with my goofy shirt on
and i popped those and then i started to
feel better started to feel a little bit
better
and now i'm proud to say that i've been
chrissy condoms i was christy celibacy
for a month after that now i've been
exclusively chrissy condoms
but even now that i've been wearing
condoms exclusively still sometimes when
i pee it burns a little i'm like do i
did i get one bat did one sneak through
the condom
or do you think that that's just me
being hyperactive and anxious if i'm
using the condoms you wouldn't worry
about the std
i think what do you say i think you
could have muscle memory probably in
your penis or something that and it re
it has that recall a little bit of
having the
symptom have you ever got sniped you've
got burnt with an std yep i got
something one time i was living with a
guy this guy named ken actually had a
couple cats dude and he used to get
stoned and make him do tricks in the
living room
right jump in these boxes yeah and uh
and when i was leaving when i was moving
out he said hey
so people are going to come look at the
uh the place you know okay
and so some lady came by and checked it
out and she was attractive and so i
started hitting on her right
and um and then that night
she and i went out right and he just
said to me he's like dude do not hook up
with this young lady
who is potentially going to live here
you know right like i need somebody to
live here
right i will not do that right and then
i hooked up with her that night
in the room right next to his room and
you went raw daddy
i i i don't believe i had any condoms at
the time
and uh would you catch the clap
gonorrhea no she caught something from
me
but she told me she said hey you have
something
and i don't know if i did have something
because i didn't have something before i
think she was lying
but then one of us had something and uh
and you had to go get rid of it yeah i
got chlamydia but it was good though but
you
never had any symptoms of the chlamydia
it wasn't bad no but you just go get
something you get rid of it and that's
the only scare that right it's like it's
kind of like a sore throat but for your
dick
your way it's like your dick is almost
going through a tough time after a war
or something it feels like yeah
it's a little beat up it's like your
dick yes just on the injured reserve
list but it's it's gonna make a full
comeback
yeah yeah it's almost exciting a little
it's like a little bit of a badge of
you know i hear from older men who used
to be a badge of honor back in the day
but how do you come back
he has chlamydia you know how do you
combat being single pain you know let's
do a champagne
and getting all the attention that you
do from females how do you how do you
not
fall into a sex addict hold do you just
not respond to people because sometimes
i text you and you don't text back
and i want to know if there's ladies out
there that feel that way as well oh i
don't know man i mean i think
uh how do i not i mean i'll do some
flirting here and there you know like
but you don't respond to all these
ladies on the dm no because i'm
constantly responding and i have to i've
been
i've made a very recent effort like the
last 72 hours i actually posted a video
on my stories and i said hey i know i
give you guys a lot of energy i love you
thank you so much for your support but
if i leave you on scene or if i just
double tap the message don't
don't take it disrespectfully i just i
gotta i gotta take care of me first
because i'm gonna live a life yeah i was
fully
too much invested in that phone and in
those dm's and i just have
you know and there was a point where i
was having sex no condoms and then i
even having sex with the condoms i'm
like
even though you're protecting yourself
which is good you're still the act is
still
you're still delving into all this
energy and all this oh yeah it's a ton
of extra energy
i haven't recently haven't really had as
much energy to really just be out
milling around you know
jerking off a lot trying not to jerk off
that much i did masturbate yesterday i
didn't want to
so that was really a kind of a wild
event but um
do you watch porn no try not to watch
porn i don't jerk it like this either i
don't know i've
i lay my penis on my stomach and i put
my hands like this and i rub the base of
my penis and i come into my belly button
oh wow what yeah that's always the way
i've mastered it sounds so french i feel
like it's always the way i masturbate
man i make like a little [ __ ] a [ __ ]
with my thumbs and i rub the bass hit it
nick
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't make you there
you're rapping but
um yeah and i blow it alone into my
belly button yeah i used to let it glay
glaze over too and just my
shirts or shorts were always stuck to my
belly but i used to rip it off when i
was a kid and i was
i would always have a cut in my belly
button people thought it used to have my
belly button pierced but it wasn't it
was
from the [ __ ] dried up on my stomach that
would rip off god brother
yeah dude are we doing all right on this
podcast is this all right i think we're
good all right
this is fantastic i know that if i
ejaculate i would use it now
when i was young i wouldn't do anything
with it i would deposit it or ejaculate
into like a bowl or into a um
you know into a toilet or something all
right now i will actually use some of it
on my body as like a
you know legitimately as an ointment or
a sav i've never been in a voluntary
gay sex act but when i was a kid i was
like the runt of my friend group i was
like 10 and my friends were 13 14. i
could see that and the mckenzie brothers
one time i was taking his [ __ ] were were
they red-headed
uh no but they were twins and they had
shaved heads they were crazy irish kids
from queens
one of them sat on my legs when i was
taking a [ __ ] and the other one jumped
on my mom's sink and skull [ __ ] me two
pumps
and my head hit off the back of the
backs i swear to god
the back ceramic tile and knocked down
one of my mom's ceramic tiles and
and i told it i was horsing around
playing ball but really i got skull
[ __ ] by
by one of these dudes and i remember
tasting a little bit of his pre-comment
yeah it was weird man i took one right
off the uvula and i did it
and i and i did in uh that's a hot i
didn't like it
no the problem is i didn't like it i did
not like it but i also didn't hate it so
that's why i'll say
i can confidently tell you that i'm a
hundred i'm 100
sure i am not gay but i'm also 100 sure
i'm not straight
so you tell me what that means well i
think there's a there's a thing called
where
element of surprise gay where somebody
surprises you with a gay act
like a pearl harbor gay yeah like pearl
harbor but yeah suddenly you're just
resting and then a bunch of wieners fall
in your house
a sneak attack yeah yeah like that kind
of thing is like because there's been
times where
you knew when i've been walking you know
when we've been in new york when we were
very close
i was definitely falling in love with
the conversations we were having i was
about to hold your hand or something
like that really
yes you always used to remember there
was one time you went here wearing
pinstripe pants like locomotive pants
yeah i used to love those pants and i
bought them very cheap yeah man those
locomotive pants i remember yeah you
know all aboard
you know because you kind of have a
little bit of a [ __ ] cake ass i got
that keister bruh you could do got a
keystone got that german keister
here's a white guy right here from lord
of the rings let's see what he has
literally does chris know
there's literally a two percent chance
that you'll die if you get the
coronavirus
two it's just the flu
gang gang gang bro i didn't say anything
about the corona virus though i
we use to solicit questions for you the
video of you having anxiety tuesday
right so i think he thinks you're going
a little bit
well the whole thing about anxiety
tuesday you know hopefully get some new
fans come over to me the anxiety tuesday
i never do it on a tuesday
um i don't do it every two every i do it
and once every other week and it's
always playing it's always
sarcasm and satire about something so
that coronavirus video
although i'm appearing to be saying i'm
anxious about it the point of anxiety is
to be satire because i agree with him
that
it's not something to really worry about
yeah i think it's not something to worry
about i feel like i mean
but also and then in two weeks you and i
could be deceased you know it could be
i wouldn't be shocked if something a
disease gets created that
that we can't solve um i think the
chinese created it in the lab
i don't think i think people like eminem
kind of i think exactly
happy black history month well oh thank
you and also i want to also happy
women's month thank you oh yeah it is
women's month
yes 5g now there's a theory out there
that 5g
created have you seen this who's 5g you
see wrapper as well no 5g the wireless
oh okay yeah 5g wireless which was
created over there in wuhan
right the wuhan clone yeah that that is
where
that that's the thing that created it i
don't think for a second that it wasn't
created
in a lab it feels like it feels like it
was created in a lab
to cause hysteria as just something else
you can blame donald trump for
i i wouldn't be surprised if the
democrat i wouldn't be surprised if
ocasio-cortez
and the wuhan lab created yeah straight
out of wuhan
if and some and elizabeth warren and joe
biden and all those liberals
cucks created the the the
the coronavirus put that [ __ ]
made the masks with the master made in
china which everyone wears they dip
those in coronavirus sell the mass to us
and we spread it
and it crashes the economy gets trump
out of office but here's the truth
you can't get trump out office he'll
always be here to stay yeah yeah
yeah i mean he could be here for a long
time social media conspiracies blame
chronovirus on 5g internet
this is what i'm talking about right
here and this is um she'll get kissed on
this lady will get cracked open and
cleaned out
uh i like her lips yeah this lady is uh
by the way i just wanted to say i was
joking about the trump democrat i was
just kidding i have no political
affiliation
oh dude look i think that i don't hate
trump i don't love him
anytime somebody starts winning they
definitely release a lot of
information to like try and cannibalize
remember they said a few weeks ago that
the russians were
russian bots were supporting bernie
remember that like what like it's just
like it just never ends i don't believe
the news anymore i'm not a news behavior
but i will say this though now that's
interesting theory that 5gy
that 5g created it that that that's
what's causing it
because wouldn't it be interesting if
they had a a technological advancement
that we don't know the side effects of
which is probably most of them
right that we don't know the side
effects like what if we created like a
wireless or some sort of a
you know a thing that's flowing through
our body sometimes through the air
and it causes a disease in us that could
it sounds like pretty feasible
pretty feasible but it's so far have
there been people that have beaten the
coronavirus and 100
cleared it already and it's gone most
people most people
yeah that's a thing it's one of those
things yeah you got to show me a dead
bro
yeah smad bruh show me a dead before i
go full well some people are dying but
it seems like it's more elderly
where yeah but that's just a dead an old
person dies and they should do a snap of
them oh here's
granny left you want to see somebody at
the top of their [ __ ] game yeah
drop dead of the coronavirus yeah dude i
want to see tyson fury frickin take you
know
yeah take it yeah
[Laughter]
92 000 cases 48 000 have recovered 3
000 have died that's worldwide yeah
and then so the flu i bet those 3 000
are babies and
old people so the seasonal flu kills way
more than that
okay okay i mean it's listen you can
worry about everything
here's a guy right huh there's a guy
from obviously or
was it from the 1920s a good guy yeah
he's got a nice mustache
one of those strong men with the oh yeah
with the 200-pound dumbbells he votes
for trump
what's going on y'all your boy shane dog
here what's up helensburg washington
wanted to let you both know i love both
you guys you guys are both
two of my favorite comedians you guys
give me something to look forward to
every week and you guys
make me laugh non-stop you guys are
killing it and please keep doing what
y'all are doing
now this question here is a little bit
more directed towards
crystal clear chrissy a little chlamydia
chrissy over here i need to ask him a
real serious question
i'm going to new york for the first time
i got nominated for an award for my
college radio show and so did my station
so i'm going out there i'm going to be
put up in
manhattan pretty close to madison square
garden and there's a lot of things you
can do in new york but i want to know
what your authentic
new york experience is for some west
coast kid
trying to go out and be an east coast
cutie with a smoothie
out here in these streets okay and theo
i'd like to know
where what's your favorite spot in new
york what do you like about new york i
want your opinion on new york
okay gang gang and ladder 14
yeah that's nice that's nice um i like
yeah i like uh i like uh
two out of the three your fan so far i'd
have lisps you got a heavy lisp fan
yeah got lit yeah we got a lot of damage
uh damaged dudes
yeah so i like that kid a lot he's got
an endearing voice i think anyone with a
little bit
of a lisp like that it's endearing to me
i would like to list down the radio do
you think he has a lisp though i think
he has a list i
kept wiping my cheeks i thought he was
spitting on me through the camera
but i might just have a you you could
have unique shape you have a very unique
shaped head what if the sound's not
coming in right
that's true my head is [ __ ] up no but
i like that kid i liked his mustache i
like he seemed like a real nice kid so
what i'm going to tell him to do
is when he's come to come to
i'm going to say you could come through
them come through to my crib yep that's
what i'm going to say is that unique
experience
just for him he could come to and he
could come tickle me with that mustache
just like the mackenzie brothers yeah no
um
i think i think what he should do is go
get a slice of pizza from
joe's in the west village by the comedy
seller i think he should go see a
stand-up show
at the comedy cellar or if one of his
comedians that he knows
he's a fan of his performing in new york
city go see him or her
headline at gotham or caroline's comedy
club if not go
see go down to the comedy cellar or the
stan comedy club or new york comedy club
these are great venues
um to see a show go get a slice of pizza
from joe's
i would say if he's never been there
it's just an experience to walk over the
brooklyn bridge
because it's scary as [ __ ] when you get
into the middle because it's only wooden
planks so you can see down
hundreds of feet below you and you'll
fall to your death definitely see
brooklyn i would go to bay ridge
brooklyn
along with williamsburg and some of the
trendy you know quinoa flea market
places also go to deep brooklyn like go
to bay ridge because it's like a
different experience because
in williamsburg you know it'll be like i
said quinoa and flea markets and
scooters but then in bay ridge
like the day after trump won the
election in 2016
there was a cafe out there giving out
free black and white cookies
so you want to see both extremes of you
know
they gave they were giving cups of
marinara sauce into my daughter's
halloween trick-or-treat bag at nino's
pizza on third avenue that's beautiful
and they're calling it bats blood
so it's different different types of
experiences in brooklyn so i would go
see that
um and then you could come you could
come with me uh if you're there on a
tuesday afternoon we go take my father
to dialysis
at college of staten island hospital if
you'd like to come there you can come
see um him get his blood
filter how many bags is he doing
i want to say two bags two three bags
easy work
yeah yeah you want to talk about farts
this guy
he doesn't my father doesn't wear
underwear anymore yeah cause he
constantly shits his pants well dude if
you're running on somebody else's blood
who knows what kind of gas is in it
that's true
you know that's true you got to think
about that i really like your fan i like
this part of the podcast where fans come
in
dude the best fans man the best
listeners the best group we got such a
yeah the whole it's just it's constantly
amazes me man
and that young fella said he's going to
new york for the first time and what did
he ask me
uh what do you like about new york
what's your new york experience you got
to go down to alphabet city man
that's what you got to say it's the last
place to get still get mugged anywhere
in manhattan i feel like kind of in that
area you got to go down there
or down up maybe second and b or
something or it goes even further go to
c
or d yeah a and b is a little hipster a
hunka doc now but once you get to c
it starts to fade and then d you're in
the full hood yes avenue d you
you will get stabbed right now there you
go and that it's the last place you can
still do it anywhere else is just more
it's just changed a lot the bronx you
could still get stabbed a little bit but
the bronx is going too far away but if
you want to be on the island of
manhattan i agree with theo go to avenue
d to get yourself shanked
yeah get shanks see somebody sell a gram
learn a little bit of spanish or
something
do it all you know they just have a
different vibe down there it's still a
little
risque and that's what i like you could
do you know you do
you know there's a lot of the dark arts
basically brother i just also want to
send a quick shout out r.i.p
to the neighborhood crackhead that i
grew up with which is also
see i would where i grew up in ridgewood
bushwick it used to be a place where you
could get stabbed but unfortunately now
it's all like vegan
cupcake stuff but there still was the
neighborhood crackhead homeless guy who
was i mean we thought he was gonna die
in 1997 he just uh recently scottie
karate
just passed away and he was the
neighborhood guy used to he would sing a
billy joel song and then he would do
whatever thing
anything you wanted him to do he would
do for a dollar remember one time he
backflipped
into this shards of glass knocked
himself unconscious and then we just put
a dollar on his chest
or he would do you know roofing work he
would fix
anything you give him a dollar he'd call
him scotty karate and he would have no
shirt on and sweatpants
uh almost 12 months a year damn so and
he survived for a long time just wanted
to say shout out scotty karate
yeah rip scotty and also yeah they had a
guy bus and he was mentally challenged
or something happened to him and he was
um
he used to ride a bike a woman's bike
that had like a little baby seat in the
back
and the baby seat was always empty you
know and he said he had a little husband
that used to
and people were always like damn where's
your little husband at and so he would
always just
tell us he had a little bit of a he had
like a little husband that used to he
was looking for him or something
yeah i don't know what happened to that
guy but i just i it's funny to grow up
the way we grew up like how you grew up
in the
like it's very relatable like you grew
up in the deep south
and i grew up in kind of the deep
brooklyn
deep brooklyn where it's like you had
your they were just different names but
but like like for example like we both
have neighborhood crackheads or we both
have like crazy uncles like i have an
uncle
who somebody robbed my mother um and
and then at the local baldega he used to
hang out the local bodega
and i guess they had this robbery ring
going down his bodega they would steal
women's purses and steal their credit
cards and their money or whatever
whatever
and they stole my mom's purse one day on
the corner and then a couple of days
later my uncle was in the bode because
he was just chilling drink beers there
and they were talking about how they
just ripped off this lady and he was
like what's she look like and
and my uncle's like oh that's my
sister-in-law you know he didn't know or
he said it in his head that's my
sister-in-law
and so whatever they kept drinking
continuing drinking drinking and then
later on that night
my uncle i didn't know this i was a
little kid i only found this out a
couple years ago the guy
nah what he did was he took they got
drunk they went back into my uncle's
garage which is in the back
back door out of my house and my uncle
beat him up and then tied him up
and uh melted the skin off his knees
with a blowtorch
jesus for stealing my mom's bag and then
he got my mom's couldn't get the credit
cards back but he got the cat he got
cash the amount of cash that he thought
she would have he got it back
so it's like that's a crazy uncle you
i'm sure you have maybe not that exact
story but a crazy uncle
yeah no we don't i mean it's it's a i
think it was just growing up in a
different time too and people could do
more stuff without everybody constantly
ratting everybody
out and no twitter's just a big snitch
fest on there man it's just so many
snitches we got a question that came in
from a guy right here
oh yeah yeah we run it we good on time
uh theo's got about
five yeah we're good yeah and this guy's
in a free conch
this is crystalline supporter right here
this guy looks a little dirty but like a
nice guy yeah he looks like he's
what he's done i bet he's done chef work
or just some ufc but i like it hey
what's up theo what's up chrissy d
baby gorgeous hope you guys are doing
great um
i'm my name's nick i am from aurora
illinois
and my question for uh chris actually
for both of you if you both
could answer this would be great um but
for chris i know that you
had started a career in physical therapy
and
i was wondering what was the moment and
what made you decide to
pursue stand up full-time and what like
what was going on i'm always curious to
know like
what it was that made you transition
into uh different career paths like it
was stand-up maybe just a hobby
was it always a passion um and how was
that for you
how did that go and for you as well theo
like what were you doing when you
decided
that you were gonna do stand up and
become a comedian full-time and how was
that like for you as well
uh it's something i'm always interested
in to know with uh
with anyone that pursues something as
crazy as stand up so uh thanks guys
thank you so much i appreciate it have a
great rest of the day
gang gang gang bro gang thank you for
very articulate i did not expect him to
be as articulate and well-spoken and
well-mannered
uh and soft like in a positive way yeah
as he was i thought it was going to come
out
because last time i did your podcast
your fans were just coming out swinging
saying i want to fight you
[ __ ] you but now yeah because because
they were only going off
what they had seen of me and what they
had seen in me was you and i are ripping
each other
from opie but now again positive because
i came on your show
and some of your fans start listening to
my stuff i could see they're using
calling me baby gorgeous and
chrissy chlamydia they listen so it's a
different thing i appreciate all this
yeah look man i appreciate i'm glad that
you're here dude the good
the good thing about my hands all right
i haven't held a guy's hands like this
hold on
bro huh you got those [ __ ] perfect
ass fingers they're not perfect dude
very very like kind of the hands of the
you could barely [ __ ] choke somebody
if they have somebody else just come and
help you
nah dude they're [ __ ] good in there
and you don't bite your nails either
um i do my thumbs are good you got sexy
ass cuticles
really i think so look at this finger
kind of oh that that finger is
disgusting
that looks like e.t yeah yeah that's
gross yeah you actually fingers are a
little long
yeah i mean they're fingers though they
shouldn't be real not long
you could just rock your toes man with
no i'm just my feet are disgusting they
grow over each other i could easily see
that it's disgusting yeah you almost
you look like somebody who would have
webbed feet almost i don't have web feet
but i believe
i was born with broken feet and they
never fixed it yes i just
my feet are broken take care of yourself
dude okay that's what i'm saying you
look like a guy that definitely was in
the band in the school band even though
he wasn't really in it
yeah you look like you're like the
marching thing with the flag
yeah yeah dude you look like my my third
grade gym teacher mrs klein
but yeah she was like this lesbian we
used to call a liu kang you kind of look
like luke
from street fighter if he was a white
dude it had money
thanks man yeah um that's awesome but
but
ominous questions now let's answer his
question
you want to start yeah so uh yeah what
was i doing i mean i was always doing
something else on the side
um until comedy was just enough of a job
you know
i think at a certain point it just kind
of chooses you i always
i think even until about like 10 years
in i was like am i going to keep doing
this am i going to keep doing this
at some point i have to grow up it feels
like comedy for me always felt like a
place where i could
i could just be i never had to grow up
you get to travel all the time you get
to escape whatever was going on in your
regular life you had to you always got
to get out of town if you were
about to be in a relationship i got to
go i got to get out of you know there
was always
you're always on the go you never to be
in one space you never had to really
kind of deal with your
with yourself i guess and like so comedy
always gave me that the ability to
escape i felt like
and then at a certain point i was like
oh i'm getting older i need to figure
out
um am i gonna have uh you know what am i
gonna do here how am i gonna have a real
future
and then yeah i think at some point it
just kind of chose me it was like okay
there's enough here where i can survive
you know so i'm gonna stay
what i always liked about you is you
were a guy that you had to really
pro not that it mattered but there was a
lot of proving that you had to do to
your peers because when you started out
it was real world and then you start
doing stand-up and already people like
nah
he's a real world guy he's not a real
stand-up and then your career like you
said was like just maintaining
maintaining maintaining did the netflix
special and it's just maintaining
and then you start to prove yourself in
the podcast game and then they say
oh well he's just starting to podcast
you know he's still the real world
guy but then you start to explode with
the podcast and then it got to the point
was like
now i've shed that real world thing i
don't think anybody
i know for a fact no one even thinks
about that with you anyway like that was
something he did
15 years ago and now it's just like
great podcaster great
stand-up it's matt so i don't sometimes
as a peer of yours in the comedy world
we i know this i'm like that
was pretty insane i was able to do all
that the random fan may not know that
they just like oh
i've always [ __ ] with theo but it's
like where you had to come from
because you could have easily quit it's
my point because you say in 10 years
it's like
aft i'm sure you heard it because if i
heard it in new york then you heard it
was like oh it's the real world dude
but that's you know we don't want to be
known as that like just now
am i starting to shed oh you that guy
from guy code where it's like that's a
part of me
that's i'm proud of it but now it's like
they know my name a little bit they know
my podcast they know me for stand up not
for
being a talking head and you are not
known for being on a reality show yeah
you know
so it takes a lot of work to do that so
i'm i'm always noticing about you and i
think it's dope
thanks man but i will say that you're a
[ __ ] no i'm kidding
dude if i'm a [ __ ] bro hey no offense
if anybody is a [ __ ] or and
and still refers to themselves as that
that's why i don't say that word i
apologize
i didn't say that i i said it so if you
want to edit it out yeah and just put
quotes on their mind and just refer to
him
yeah um because i was just i didn't have
anything to say
the problem is i because i said that
nice thing about you and i was thinking
of a joke and it slipped
so i just went to a very uh a prima
immature thing and i just called it i
just said that and i just
i have two gay friends and they're
saying they say look i am a [ __ ]
right and i'll be like dude you don't
don't say that i'll be like no i
am that's what i am so everybody does
different something different some
people want
but i'll be there i'll tell you this
dude if i'm gay bro i would be shocked
see if i'm gay i'd be if i'm gay i'd be
relieved
yeah that's the thing with me is because
i can't even really take a good look
because my father's still alive so my i
got an old school father
75 year old brooklyn you know tony balls
is his nickname so i can't
even look inside to see if there's a
little gay in there because it feels
like there's a little game there
like like i'm plant-based i'm on a
plant-based diet right now and you're
building like a strong gay you're built
like a strong
and i'm a strong gay and people tell me
you know i'm a power i'm a i'm a power
bottom
um i got a big fat ass um i love whitney
houston
my favorite movies little women or
pretty woman um
you know i [ __ ] jerk off to guys like
all those things
all those things are gay so sometimes i
feel like i can say that
f word which is derogatory and i don't
mean any harm but i can say because i
know deep down i
am one i know that there's one just
pouncing around in there
um oh yeah i can see a little tigger
inside of you man yeah because the thing
is even though i did get two pumps
i got skull [ __ ] by the mckenzie
brothers two pumps i did give it a lick
as it was coming off
so that's so that changes everything
you know bro that's an alarm if things
get too yeah
really and i think we just yeah man my
fault guys
can i tell you a quick comment why i
like the mckinsey brother's fault
yes what do you guys think well no lou
kang um
real quick um i started stint just to
answer the family question thank you for
that question
i was a pediatric physical therapist i
have a doctorate degree in physical
therapy
it's crazy dude it really is crazy man
when you get skull [ __ ] you your paths
change
you know so so i went and i became a
physical therapist
i was working with children pediatric
mentally physically handicapped children
was a beautiful job
but then simultaneously i got on guy
code and guy code really started to pop
off on mtv2 and then they created girl
code
and that really started to pop off so
what happened was see the thing is this
is you know there's a lot of a lot of
the people who are watching the shows
were younger people
18 19 20 21 22 was a college younger
people show on mtv and mtv2
and it's very well known that older
women sometimes will give birth
to a child with a disability you know
there's a lot of testing that women as
they get older have to do it's less and
less now but it's still
a thing that's what people say on my
biological clock but what's also not as
known but is very true
is younger women 17 16
pre they don't have the proper prenatal
care and they don't know that they're
pregnant so their children are born with
high disability rates as well
definitely in high sugar too they always
at sonic always at sonic
yeah oh um so so they so they
uh a lot of the moms and dads of the
children i was treating
were young people that were watching guy
code and girl code
and the principal of the school i was
working i was like look we found out
you're doing comedy you're doing these
tv shows and they're like it's not
you can't be treating handicapped
children and also doing a show about the
guide code to hiding your boner so
you're going to have to choose
and so it was really this little kid my
little man aaron
great kid he was in a wheelchair had
cerebral palsy so cognitively he was
fine
no problems with speech or his mind
worked like
our minds but his legs didn't work from
cerebral palsy so he was sitting in his
wheelchair one day we were throwing the
ball at him you know he would throw it
at me i would you know rifle it off his
legs he couldn't feel it anyway
so i would just rifle it up you know
light him with you know burn him with
cigarettes
whatever it you know he is feel [ __ ] i
would tell him to close his eyes i would
just yeah
whatever no light his pants on fire
joke around have a pet bat bite him yeah
no i'm kidding obviously i'm kidding but
what he's your agent now
yeah he's my agent no so aaron so um
so aaron um told me i was when i was
flirting with this idea of leaving
uh physical therapy he's six years old
but the thing is when you're
six-year-old kid that's got a disability
you're
you're so wise beyond your years so the
reason because the you know man asked me
what why what made me change i was
always flirting with the idea of leaving
for a year i was like
i should leave i need to jump two feet
in if i really want to do stand up and
then
it got to the point where aaron told me
we were talking throwing the ball back
and forth and i was like i kind of want
to leave stand up
i kind of want to leave physical therapy
to do stand-up but i'll miss you guys so
much so i don't know if i could do it
and he was like well it isn't stand-up
isn't being a comedian your dream
and i said yeah it is and he goes so why
wouldn't you go
why would you go do it if that's what
you always want to do and i was like um
i was like i don't know i'm going to
miss you guys and he was like
he and he said to me he was like i'm not
going anywhere i can't walk
i'm always gonna be sitting in this
chair waiting for you he's like but i
wanna
aaron said this to me he goes i wanna i
think it's pretty cool if i could see
one of my thera
my teachers he called you call his
teacher one of my teachers on tv
he said i would think that was pretty
cool he said and if i had that
opportunity i would go and i would hope
you would want to watch me and be proud
of me
and he said we're all proud of you i
think you should go do it and go live
your dream damn and i was like damn
and then because i would say because
because he said because i and then i
said to him
i said to him i was like how are you so
smart how are you so smart like this and
how are you so brave
and then he said like i'll never forget
he was like well
he was like you see mr chris it was like
a [ __ ] movie he's like you see mr
chris
he said when you can't walk or use your
legs and you're in a wheelchair
he said you have all day to sit and
think he said so i'm thinking about you
and i think you should go do it and then
i swear to god i [ __ ] relieve myself
hysterical crying like three hours later
i told the principal i was like i'm
gonna leave is this patch adams i think
no dude it was legit it was [ __ ]
legit man it's uh yeah no it's wild
i mean it's uh [ __ ] and then i talked
about it i put chinese finger traps and
[ __ ] on his toes i took those off
because he couldn't feel it anyway yeah
did he really say that man i swear he
was
remarkable yeah to think about how much
time you have to think just how still
probably your world gets when you can't
even
because it was that that pushed me and
also i this is true too i had sex with
four of the teachers at different times
and the heat was starting to get turned
up because they all found out about it
so they were starting to get a little
heated in that physical therapy
petri dish with that drip drop so
between aaron telling me to go live my
dream
and and these girls you know about to
press charges it was it was time to
leave
damn
god man you can check them out on
history of hyenas man check me out on
historyhyenas.com
uh and you can see him and don this
weekend where are you guys going to be
at no well i don't
donny where are you going to be i'm
going to be in jacksonville this weekend
you can see him at the jacksonville uh
comedy zone when does this episode come
out theo
thursday thursday this thursday okay so
go to my website christiecomedy.com i
got a bunch of dates up there
march 19th uh gramercy theater live
history hyenas first show sold out
second show available and then april
29th
wall street theater norwalk connecticut
i also in april i have
vancouver boston raleigh north carolina
i got philadelphia i just put seattle
and portland up
in october uh aladdin theater in neptune
theater so come check me out i got a
bunch of dates chrisdcomedy.com and
check out the podcast history of hyenas
with giannis pappas
amen man and thank you so much for
coming dude and sorry if i'm a little
bit tired it's just been hard it just
feel tired
i hope it was a good episode man i think
it was a lot of fun i wish i could be
more fun
like just more engaging sometimes i'm
just a little bit exhausted i like your
energy i like
i like your energy this way because i
like it because it's really you
it's really just like you and then i
like in the beginning
like when you get like a little catty
[ __ ] energy i kind of like that about
you
thanks when i was like talking to you
like hey save for the podcast i kind of
like that
and then and then i like that you go in
waves and zones
with this thing yeah i have to pee too
that's why i [ __ ] been in that zone
but i love the story about the kid in
the wheelchair i loved
the fact that he inspired you man that
[ __ ] is pretty powerful
you got you got real good [ __ ]
positive energy and i wish that we hung
out more but i text you you don't text
back anymore
what's the problem well i will so i'm
gonna start going through
i want to start facetiming you more too
when you pee is it clear or is it darker
okay i'll tell you this bro i bet it's a
lot clearer than some of the patches
you've had right
yeah dude that is for sure yeah man but
uh but i've been but i'm just waiting
for these last
std results and then i'm gonna be
celibate man i'm gonna try to take two
months off no [ __ ] i'm not saying i
won't [ __ ] guys
but definitely no girls yeah right yeah
but if you're only banging guys because
you're
taking a break from women that's not
okay bro you have to actually
be a gay man man i know i feel like guys
can't go back you can't be a bisexual
guy you could be a bisexual girl but
guys i feel like once you
hook up with a guy you're gay yeah which
is fine dunkin donuts remember that
dunkin donuts no what's that from uh jim
norton over there on the opi show i love
jim norton
dunkin donuts dude
it got weird though towards him because
opie and jim were always arguing they
were arguing a lot there was a lot of
tension in there
and to be honest man people would hit me
up because at the end i was on
at the end literally every time jim was
out opi would call me in to be the
villain because i was you know
hungry i live right there hungry for
this for the opportunity
um and uh and so a lot of fans would ask
me questions
hey what's going on with opie and jim
and and the truth is i didn't know
because
they i only saw them argue once and that
was live on the air when everybody else
saw it
yeah when it was before after i had no
idea i would see jim at the comedy
seller wouldn't talk about it i
when i would speak to opie privately he
wouldn't talk about it so anything that
the fans
i don't know yeah you know yeah saying
people would ask me about it i just felt
like
i think it's hard to work with anybody
for a long time to start that early in
the morning
you know opie been there for a while i
think it's just tough to make that it's
tough to make things fit you know a lot
of things but
anyway i shouldn't have brought that up
i didn't mean to get it up i just dinner
tonight
uh you can't do it i probably can't
actually you want to do it me you and
donny yeah scotty bangs i just have to
go
i have to go to yoga right now no but i
mean after yoga yeah
we're going to do it man i want to buy
what do you want to eat i don't know
something italian
you want to do something italian yeah
scotty bangs are you you need are you
getting a trim
oh yeah i actually i got podcasts
tonight oh sorry guys
he has a podcast too i'd be honored too
another bachelor podcast no i know his
name's nick but aren't we calling him
scotty bangs or do we call them nikki
banks
oh my fault yep karate nikki banks
it's so good i don't even know where i
am right dude you want to piss in my
hood
i want to go dude all right bro i'm
gonna [ __ ] kiss you on the lips right
now
what get it on camera what do we do can
i do it no
come on man stop being anti-gay just go
let's go get him dude if i'm gay i will
tell you bro
i'm not just being gay for no reason man
yeah thank god these are these are uh
wow it's too much wow it's too much guys
be good no get that away yes
that's what i'm saying
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine
that light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
and now i've been moving way too fast